sometimes the most elusive anomaly in
this world is true love the endless
carousel of blind dates the hours of
fruitless swiping on a variety of dating
apps and the cringe-inducing awkwardness
of bar hopping can sometimes be all too
much to bear but don't give up just yet
if modern dating's got you down then
we've got the perfect show for you it's
time for some matchmaking merriment the
likes of which the world has never seen
so sit back relax and get ready to fall
in love live from the scp foundation
it's the scp dating game
we've assembled the foundations most
eligible bachelors bachelorettes and
entities of indeterminate gender who are
ready to secure contain and protect your
heart without further ado let's get
right to it and meet our first fabulous
contestant meet scp-096
if you like the introverted type then
this bachelor might just be for you he
prefers to keep to himself and spends
most of his time hiding his face and
crying uncontrollably in the corner of a
cell isn't it refreshing to find a guy
who's so in touch with his emotions it
might take some work to get him out of
his shell but if you're patient and kind
then you'll be surprised at what he's
capable of 096 enjoys long walks through
the remote mountains sad movies and
being appreciated for what's on the
inside rather than what he looks like
just make sure you honor his boundaries
and never ever look at his face and you
could be the companion this shy guy is
looking for but maybe you're looking for
someone more talkative the kind of
person who commands the room at a dinner
party with an amazing story if your idea
of the perfect partner is someone who
has lived a wild fascinating dangerous
life then you'll love our next dashing
contestant he's scp-1867
but you can call him lord theodore
thomas blackwood that's right not only
is he charming in bold but he has a
title too don't be fooled by the fact
that he's a tiny sea slug lord blackwood
is a master adventurer and hunter and
has faced some of the most incredible
and deadly things this world has to
offer all he wants is someone to share
them with if you're ready to travel
across the globe with a gentleman slug
then get ready to pack a bag and set off
on life's great adventure together maybe
you prefer your experiences to be more
digital no jet setting for you you'd
rather stay home and flirt through your
phone if you're into the technological
side of love but are looking for an
alternative to the dreaded dating apps
then this next contestant could be the
one for you all you have to do to meet
them is download one free app mal over
1.0.0 and you get to meet
scp-1471
this is one attentive partner they'll
text you every few hours and you'll get
to see them everywhere even when they're
not really there if you're feeling a bit
put off by their skull face and shadowy
body maybe you should work on being a
little less shallow don't judge a book
by its cover they just really want to
check in and see how you're doing and
make sure you never ever feel lonely but
hey maybe that's all a little too much
darkness for you maybe you're looking
for someone sweeter meet
scp-2396 also known as miss sweetie
she's a lovely lady who's all about
appreciating the bright side of life
even when things get sour if you get
hungry while on a date with her good
news she can spontaneously generate her
own hard candy no more paying through
the nose for movie theater concessions
pure tate's got the snacks covered now
be advised she's not the fondest of men
so the fellows out there might want to
steer clear but everyone else should try
and see just how sweet life together can
be are you feeling love sick and
starting to think there might not be a
cure then you might need a doctor a
plague doctor to be exact our next
eligible anomaly is scp-049
and not only does he have an impressive
career i mean come on he's a doctor but
he's also a big believer in working
toward the greater good this dapper
refined frenchman so you know he's a
natural romantic believes in healing the
world taking care of others and making
sure everyone is feeling well if you're
looking for someone to heal your heart
look no further this beaked bachelor has
got the magic touch speaking of
impressive resumes if a doctor isn't
enough for you then how about a king
that's right the scarlet king himself is
our next contestant this hunk of burning
hatred is tall dark and unknowable by
our tiny mortal minds if you're
attracted to power influence and
unbridled evil and don't mind he's got a
few children already then you can take
the throne by his side and reign over
chaos together some people look for a
partner that's powerful and intimidating
but others prefer an everyman
scp-507 is a friendly average guy who
just so happens to be extremely well
traveled we're not talking about a
semester abroad in europe this guy's
travel history is completely out of this
world he's not afraid to be spontaneous
in fact he can't stop himself from
taking a trip at a moment's notice
[Laughter]
so if you're the kind of person who's
always looking for your next weird wild
exotic getaway then 507 might just be
your perfect match you've got to be
willing to roll with some weirdness
though because some of the trips 507
takes include extreme temperatures
bizarre landscapes and an ominous
smiling man but think of the memories
you'll share that will only bring you
and your dimension hopping bow even
closer together would you take a walk on
the wild side if so you're in luck
because our next bachelorette scp-953
is a real fox no seriously she's a fox
she's highly adaptable capable of
shape-shifting and she loves to cook her
favorite dish is liver though she
prefers to eat it raw she's an elegant
charismatic lady with an appreciation
for the finer things in life like plum
wine so why not join her for a drink and
just see where it goes just be polite
don't call her a kid sooner and make
sure your date isn't anywhere near a dog
park this next eligible bachelorette is
a great fit for anyone who doesn't place
a high value on looks that's not to say
she's unattractive but you won't be able
to look at her it's
scp-347 or claudia and she just so
happens to be completely invisible
claudia has a great sense of humor a
love of pranks and a variety of talents
including lock picking with her talent
for theft you won't have to worry about
being the sole breadwinner she's a great
gal to come home to if you're sick of
spending time alone in an empty
apartment but still want your apartment
to look like it's empty just make sure
you give any house guests a heads up
before they come over that your house
isn't haunted you just have an invisible
girlfriend do you like an older man how
about a man as old as the universe
itself great news here comes
scp-343 also known as god this
good-natured silver fox is massively
powerful and apparently omnipotent he
knows absolutely everything about
everything you wouldn't be able to keep
any secrets from him but think of how
you'd wipe the floor with everyone at
bar trivia and up next we have
scp-2430 the immortal hitler clone
just kidding can you even imagine even
we wouldn't stoop that low
moving on do you like the bad boy type a
misanthrope someone you can bond with
over your shared hatred of well
everything you sound like kind of a
bummer to be honest but there's an scp
match that suits you perfectly
scp-682 would absolutely love to hate
with you this massive extremely
intelligent reptile is one rude dude
with a bad attitude 682 is also ready
for anything that life could throw at it
capable of adapting to any situation
sure this creature wants to destroy
every living thing in its path and seems
unwilling to stop until the entire world
has been eradicated but come on you can
change him if you're into boston accents
then pay close attention to our next
entry scp-527
a fancy little gentleman by the name of
mr fish why is he called mr fish i mean
come on look at him he's a guy with a
fish head he can't breathe underwater or
talk to other fish or do anything
unusual at all really he's just a guy
from boston looking for love he just so
happens to have the head of a fish with
a teeny tiny little top hat he's ready
for any formal occasion you might need
someone to accompany you too a wedding
the opera your nephew's bar mitzvah but
hey if he's not your pick there are
plenty of fish in the sea
that joke was terrible speaking of sea
our next contestant is one tall drink of
water
scp-054 the water nymph is a
shape-shifting creature made up entirely
of ordinary water that just so happens
to take on the shape of a humanoid woman
she'd love to go swimming with you have
a fun day at a water park or play a game
of shape-shifting charades if this
sounds like a wave you'd like to catch
throw on a swimsuit and get ready to
dive into a future with
scp-054 your body is mostly water so you
two already have a lot in common it's
really important to have shared
interests in a romantic partnership and
if you consider yourself a foodie then
this next contestant is for you
meet scp-082
ferdinand hailing from pants ooh la la
ferdinand speaks fluent french and
english he's always smiling the same
enormous smile no matter what life
throws at him he's tall too standing at
approximately eight feet and weighing
around 700 pounds there's just so much
of him to love this guy loves to cook
just as much as he loves to eat though
he's probably not a great fit for a
vegetarian he loves his meat he also has
a passion for fashion and culture
enjoying fine clothing television and
films novels and singing classical music
this is a man with exceptional taste and
a hunger for all of the finest things in
life if refined gentleman interests you
but you're not sure about someone with
such a voracious appetite then this next
contestant is more your speed especially
if you're a bit of an anglophile mr
deeds can be summoned via
scp-662 or the butler's handbell if you
ring it he'll appear ready to attend to
your every need a proper english butler
mr deeds is a generous partner intent on
keeping others satisfied he's an
especially good fit for someone busy who
needs a little help around the house mr
deeds is the perfect house husband ready
to greet you at the door with a hot meal
and listen to you talk about your long
day at the office just don't be afraid
to ask for what you need from him he can
help you if you don't ask the next
contestant with us today has got some
killer hair
scp-352 baba yaga has so much going for
her she's got maturity knowledge super
human healing abilities and a bite that
causes the nervous system to shut down
her hobbies include cannibalism long
stroll through the enchanted forest and
crafting web-like traps out of her hair
she's lived long enough to know exactly
what she wants and maybe what she wants
is you if you happen to speak old
russian and have a taste for human flesh
then the two of you can play house
together in a lovely forced cottage on
top of some chicken legs and abduct any
unwitting travelers that wander into
your midst you know what they say the
couple that prays together stays
together if you love an older paramore
but you're looking for someone with a
bit more masculine energy then our next
bachelor is the perfect pick
scp-106 or the old man has traveled all
the way from his pocket dimension lair
to hunt for one thing
someone to love now his appearance might
be startling at first but if you give
him a chance to get close to you he's
guaranteed to melt your heart this next
fellow has taken some time off from his
busy professional life to come here and
compete for someone special to call his
own he's a career man dedicated to his
job but he's also got room in his life
for romance it's scp 1879 the indoor
salesman he's an ambitious guy with a
passion for sales and doesn't like to
take no for an answer his hobbies
include sales sales and more sales in
addition to appearing inside your home
when you least expect it driving a hard
bargain and smooth talk he's a slick
charmer who's promising the deal of a
lifetime on a one-of-a-kind product his
heart maybe you don't want a businessman
maybe you want a guy whose career is a
bit more whimsical someone with an
artistic side a sense of humor or
someone who can clown around from time
to time well you ought to meet
scp-2094 motormouth he's a
multi-talented guy skilled at juggling
gymnastics and acrobatics and stretching
his lower jaw up to 2 meters in any
direction to engulf just about any item
never pay for storage space again motor
mouth can store anything you need him to
in his extra dimensional second stomach
you'll never be bored again that's a
guarantee now if looks are more
important to you than personality like
way more important then feast your eyes
on our next competitor it's
scp-056 a beautiful person what's your
type tall short blonde brunette redhead
beard or shaven
doesn't matter no matter what you like
zero five six will change its shape to
become appealing to you
no one knows what this entity's original
form looks like but it's always gorgeous
and it always looks like the most
appealing person an observer can imagine
talk about knowing how to read the room
if you have a more dominant personality
then you should keep looking because
this entity likes its partners on the
submissive side it knows that it's
superior to you and wants to make sure
you know it too but if you're looking
for someone gorgeous to worship and
don't mind them being rude all the time
and knowing more than you do about
everything then you and 056 can make a
life together filled with beauty and
disdain for our next contestant let's
see what's behind door number three
it's scp-303
actually this contestant is behind every
door any door anywhere no matter where
you are if there's a door it will appear
on the other side you'll know when it's
there just listen for the sound of its
wheezing breathing that sound means
you're not alone and you'll never have
to be again don't be nervous
scp-303 is more afraid of you than you
are of it love is all about facing your
fears so open up the door to your heart
and let
scp-030 come inside our next eligible
bachelor is a little bit prickly on the
outside but he's got a soft heart
beneath that spiky exterior it's
scp-2800 cactus man here to save the day
and sweep you off your feet his real
name is daniel mcintyre and yes he is
scottish not only does he have the dna
of a seguro cactus and the ability to
grow spines all over his body he also
has a super cute accent he's able to
conserve water as well using only a
third of the water a normal human being
would use so he's an ideal partner for
the particularly environmentally
conscious he may be hot but his body
tolerates extreme temperatures and keeps
him from overheating or becoming
dehydrated if you have to be stranded on
a desert island this is the man you'd
want with you this next contestant is a
real doll scp-136 loves to laugh loves
attention and is full of surprises give
her a chance and she's guaranteed to get
your heart rate up good news she's
already behind you oh wow that is a
special surprise we have with us here
the host of another classic show laugh
is fun also known as scp-2030
laffy mclaverson here is a real goofball
just a silly little prankster who enjoys
playing jokes watching inanimate objects
eat people alive and making people laugh
laugh laugh laugh
sorry i don't know what came over me
there i wasn't really myself but don't
look away yet this contestant loves
constant eye contact and wants to keep
your undivided attention scp-170
is a living work of art a sculpture to
be exact that can only move when it's
not being observed so as long as you're
keeping an eye on 173 you'll never lose
it up next is a bit of a local celebrity
around these parts dr bright his
consciousness lives inside of an amulet
and after years of trauma he's not the
best at opening up to people but if
you're okay with an emotionally
long-distance relationship you can
definitely make things work our final
contestant is looking for someone who
loves to laugh have fun and get silly
once in a while here comes the tickle
monster it's
scp-999 this gelatinous gem wants
nothing more than to cheer you up give
you a big hug and make sure you're
having a wonderful day 999 has a world
of love to share and simply coming into
contact with its slimy surface is enough
to make you smile not only does 999 help
people feel better but it also smells
good to everyone who meets it bringing a
comforting aroma to your shared home you
don't have to worry about cooking for it
either as its diet consists entirely of
candy every day is a new chance to laugh
and play with scp-999
if it tickles your fancy and heck if
you're eager to hang out with scp-999
that you don't even want to wait for a
date you can always go to scp-swag.com
and get yourself a high quality scp-999
plushie just saying so who's your lucky
date going to be do you want to play it
safe or take a walk on the wild side
take a weekend trip with scp-507 or try
to convince scp-682 that you're the only
human out there who isn't
disgusting
let us know your pick in the comments
below and let your love story finally
begin and then go check out
scp-2521 redacted and infohazard scps
explained and scp-999 tickle monster
versus the most evil scps for more of
our delightful and terrifying scp
compilations